[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
qui tient autant à l'aise mais qu'est ce
qui t'arrive ses blessures ça mais c'est
pas banal pour l'instant mettez lui son
mystère ils sont en train de le perdre
mais mais c'est pas mais c'est jean
pierre castaldi c'est pas beau ça
merci je garde ça je garde ça ne vous
inquiétez pas petite soirée amour
toujours
[Applaudissements]
ah non double soirée amour toujours un
enchaînement entre mario premier regard
et évidemment l'admirateur secret je
préparais mon interview de d'aujourd'hui
à la mairie de paris
c'était la conférence de presse des
molières mme excusez moi vous préparez
que des choses pour autant d'eau en
émission si vous avez vous préparé quoi
en fait je prépare les les étables c'est
alors donnez moi un scoop qui ont
aujourd'hui un scoop away alors elle a
serré mais damon des molières non mais
on s'en fout c'est un vrai scoop ah
ouais non on va nous dire molière
s'appelle jean baptiste pas ce qu'est ce
que je peux vous allez raconter comme
chose attend déjà battu réfléchi vallée
seront bien vous je vous le dit c'est
toi qui le paye il fait les vrais noms
mais je te le dis parce que tu bats ne
travaillais pas je m'en fous moi donc
tout le truc médias plus là tous à la
lecture bien gentil mais ici c'est
touche pas à mon pote
ce sont des choses qui me servent pour
l'émission a mais on les voit pas